so brienne of tarth defeated the hound  pardon me lady brienne she's not a sir  you're not the knight women can't be  knights  why not [ __ ] tradition  i didn't even want to be a knight  i'm no king but if i were  i'd knight you ten times over  you don't need a king any knight  can make another knight  i'll prove it  neil lady brienne  do you want to be a knight or not  neil  [Music]  so  [Music]  so  in the name of the warrior i charge you  to be brave  [Music]  in the name of the father  i charge you to be just  in the name of the mother i charge you  to defend the innocent  [Music]  arise brienne of tarth  a night of the seven kingdoms  [Music]  [Applause]  top knight of the seven kingdoms  you